former Georgia House Minority Leader
Stacey Abrams is considering joining the
crowded Democratic field for president
Abrams gained national attention during
her battle to win the hotly contested
Georgia governor's race last year which
she narrowly lost she earned the support
of former President Barack Obama and
Oprah Winfrey her well received state of
the union rebuttal this year further
fueled speculation of a presidential or
Senate bid in her newly reissued memoir
lead from the outside how to build your
future and make real change Abrams
reflects on her career in politics and
business she also shares advice for
those who want to follow in her
footsteps Stacey Abrams joins us first
on CBS this morning since her book was
reissued welcome thank you for them much
so you had a lunch with Joe Biden who's
thinking about running to it was
thinking about running lunch you talked
about the presidency and what it means
absolutely what is the presidency mean
right now I think the presidency is
about reasserting who we are as a nation
our capacity for cohesion and our
ability to talk about marginalized
communities and those who are outsiders
without excluding the the majority
there's this false dichotomy right now
that you can either talk about those who
are left out or you talk about those who
feel like they're being left out but you
can't talk about both and I think one of
the vibrant parts of our conversation
was that I believe you can talk about
identity and that means you can include
everyone everyone wants to be seen and
the best politicians are the ones who
can bring people together not by
pretending we all have the same issues
but by recognizing the obstacles that
some of us face and the opportunities
that all of us want is this the you're
saying that's challenge for the nation
is this the political challenge for
Democrats running for president because
speaking about identity is important in
primaries for both parties but it can
sometimes cause parties to be defined by
those an identity conversations
happening within the clubhouse and the
rest of the country looks and says oh
they're just talking to themselves I
actually push back on that because I
think we have to recognize that
identities pervade all of us we each
come to the space with our histories and
our challenges the worst political
spaces are the ones where you think
everyone has the exact same narrative
and everyone has the exact same
challenges that doesn't exist in a
household let alone in a nation when we
are best it's when we acknowledge that
everyone faces different obstacles but
we all want the same thing we want
education we want Economic Security we
want health care the issue is having
leaders of both parties who understand
that there are different obstacles and
different barriers and they have plans
for how you get there but they never
forget that we're all going in the same
direction during that lunch with the
vice-president let me ask you did the
conversation of a potential future
ticket between the two of you with Vice
President you being his vice president
on the ticket we talked about a lot of
things but that was not the core issue
okay what Joe Biden's record has come
under a lot of scrutiny lately his
position on school desegregation his
vote during the Clarence Thomas
confirmation his position on a new need
Anita Hill last night he said I wish I
could have done something to get her a
fairer hearing is that legitimate
scrutiny did you talk to him about that
does that matter in 2020 so I'm having
lunch and coffee and drinks and water
with everyone running for president
right who is willing to talk to me and
part of the ability to do that is that
I'm not going to talk about what we
talked about I will give broad
brushstrokes but here's an as a
politician but here's what I would say
in my book wheat from the outside I talk
about the fact that we make mistakes
based on the information we have at the
time and one of our responsibilities is
to create space for people to understand
that mistakes happen and that you can
grow and what I hope anyone running for
president will do is acknowledge
mistakes made talk about what you've
learned and then apply those new lessons
to how you intend to lead let me ask you
about the bar report because you gave an
interview where you commented on it bars
interpretation of the Moller report
right and you said that I tend to think
it's like having your brother summarize
your report card to your parents we
should be deeply suspicious especially
since he had 12 tardies in at least
three times ditching class what are you
trying to say with that I'm saying that
it is inappropriate for us to assume we
know what the mole report says until we
can read them all the report having
someone whose job it is
not simply to he's the Attorney General
but he became Attorney General in part
because he chastised Muller during the
earlier process I do not think we can
assume that what he is reported in his
summary is an accurate summary of the
report but the best way to know what was
said in the report is to read the report
and my belief is until we've seen the
report we don't know what it says
one quick mother piece of political
business you said you've been meeting
with and having drinks with everybody
who's thinking about running for
president when you drink alone
are you having somebody running for
president is a good question yes we have
Singlish breakfast tea together in the
morning i am deeply appreciative of
those who have encouraged me to run for
a variety of offices I will say the
presidency wasn't top of mind to begin
with but I think that the success I had
in our election transforming the
electorate the work I've done as a
business leader as a civic leader as a
political leader positions me to be just
as capable of becoming the President of
the United States as anyone running my
responsibilities though is to make sure
I'm running for the right reasons and at
the right time and this is not the
conversation I was having with myself
last year what was the most important
takeaway for you having lost that that
the governor's race what was the most
important I would like to say I did not
win the governor's race
and here's why I see a distinction part
of how leadership evolves especially for
those of us who are from outside the the
normative space is that we have to
characterize what happened I was not
successful in part because I think there
was mismanagement and malfeasance in the
election process but I also have an
obligation to think about what I can do
better next time and in my mind the
first responsibility was to not concede
because that validated a system that I
do not believe was proper but I also
have the responsibility to take action
because it's insufficient to simply
complain about what you don't like if
you're not doing something to fix it and
that's why I launched fair fight action
it's why we've just launched fair count
which is looking at the census process
my job and my takeaway is that I have
more work to do and my next
responsibility is to figure out how that
plays out in the electorate there are a
number
women there are a number of minority
candidates running for the Democratic
nomination is this the year one of them
ends up being the nominee I believe so
and for me that the the conversation
that led to me writing lead from the
outside is that we have to start
evolving what the face of leadership
looks like but that means we have to
have practical tips it's not enough to
dream that you want to be things you
have to have a pathway there and what
I've tried to do in this book is not
just talk about my life because I'm
vaguely interesting but more than
vaguely interesting but really I want to
talk about how I made mistakes how I
figured out solutions how I hacked
opportunity because the way we get to a
changing and more vibrant representation
of who we are is that people who don't
see themselves as part of the
conversation find that they can be part
of the conversation and did we mention
you're also a romance novelist there's
so much to talk about Daisy Abrams thank
you for your time so my lead from the
outside is on sale right now